welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode two in which
wanda's goofy sitcom dream bubble begins
to bleed
persecute socialists and get drunk on
chewing gum it's getting weirder and as
i did for episode one i am gonna comb
through this episode shot by shot for
all the easter eggs and hidden details i
spotted
spoiler warning and this video was
brought to you by privacy
privacy lets you buy things online using
virtual cards protecting your identity
and bank information on the internet and
as a treat to my viewers new privacy
customers will get
five dollars to spend on their first
purchase when they go to privacy.com
new rockstars to sign up now and if you
are interested in winning a playstation
5 reminder that our merch partners at
epic hero shop are giving away 10
playstation 5's you enter by following
their new youtube channel epic hero labs
and filling out the form at epic hero
shop.com
giveaway and they'll announce a new
winner every 10 000 subscribers they get
and speaking of merch our latest
obsession shirt and
unusual couple it's so amazing we've got
secret augmented reality easter eggs
around vision's head get your hands on
that at newrockstarsmerch.com get this
vision shirt and you can write in custom
shoutouts that we will feature in inside
marvel but on the episode it opens with
a bump in the night
actually i did over here a couple of
lads at work remarking on a few
unsavoury characters settling in the
neighborhood suggesting that the town of
west view is now feeling threatened by
outsiders presumably the forces of sword
trying to infiltrate wanda's pocket
reality now whereas episode 1 was
inspired by sitcoms like the dick van
dyke show and i love lucy episode 2
appears to be based on the late 60s
sitcom bewitched there's a very
bewitched inspired animated opening here
ah but with this one division theme
notice the melody in the beat of the
song
that is the same general syncopation of
the other big song that's featured in
this episode
the beach boys help me rhonda help me
rhonda help
help me rhonda help me rhonda plays
through the static on the radio in a way
to make it kind of sound like help me
wanda
all of this is making this episode a cry
for help for wanda
wanda ends up helping she helps vision
she helps dottie she helps save this
fragile reality from the mysterious
beekeeper by just saying no
and rewinding and as these animated
neighbors sing one
division one one division they're all
kind of like begging for her help
help to get them out of her heart the
animated west view billboard reads home
it's where you make
it interesting reflection of the way
wanda is literally constructing this
home around her with her mind as
animated vision floats their house they
do this amazing simpsons crawl space gag
by showing the horrors between the
floors
there's a few bones a cobweb and right
there that four pronged helmet looks
like the helmet of marvel
villain the grim reaper who comes from a
vision comic involving transferred
consciousness which might be part of
this show
that is avengers number 102 which could
tie into that license plate we saw
episode one
zero one zero two and remember mr hart
in episode one
asked vision if he had any skeletons in
his closet no skeletons in your closet a
vision apparently he does there are some
horrors in this house in fact my uh west
view is a graveyard theory from inside
marvel's starting to look a little less
insane
as vision drives past these neighbors
dottie's floral coat appears to have
a dark stain on it i don't think it's
part of the pattern because you don't
see any other ones that are that dark
she later references getting out blood
stains from white linen something she
has to do herself a very unsettling line
jones what the hell are you doing to
your wife
and here agnes holds her rabbits and
you're scratchy along with a martini
it's daytime agnes drinking is another
thing we should probably keep our eye on
so rehearsing their magic
act wanda talks about the talent show
acts by some of their neighbors
fred and linda are building a moat in a
fully functioning port carlos and no one
even knows why no we never do see
any act with a moat or a castle so yeah
it's a throwaway joke but it's kind of a
weird one
like why were fred and linda whoever
they are building a moat and a fortress
gate
who are they trying to protect
themselves from oh and illusion and
glamour are a nod to the stage names of
the zarkovs who live in leona new jersey
with vision and wanda in their 12 issue
comic in the 80s they start off against
them but then later kind of shelter them
the dining room wall art shows a
different fortress though
this is the hydra lab base where wanda
and her brother were experimented on
in sokovia in age of ultron so yeah all
of west view is tied to
wanda's inner thoughts and memories and
actually for our theories on how this
could all tie into the x-men going to
the mcu be sure to watch this week's
rogue theory and then we hear that bump
again
you know at first say that that sound
was a lawnmower but no no these are the
worrying blades of a helicopter then
boom
and then she finds it outside bright red
and yellow with
a sword logo it is possible this was the
helicopter we've seen the trailer
footage on the outside of west view that
maybe got a little too close to the
border and was
warped into this harmless toy and inside
marvel we talked about that
creepy episode of the twilight zone it's
a good life in which a boy in a remote
town
mind controls everyone and forces them
to bend to his will and play his game
kind of like it looks like wanda is
doing in this
and then that he terrifyingly turns a
man into a jack-of-the-box
that could be kind of what wanda is
doing here and every time we hear a bump
it could be a different member of sword
trying to break in
monica the helicopter and at the end of
the episode someone as that beekeeper
figure but as wanda tries to figure this
out her concentration is broken
look it's the star of the show
it is as if agnes doesn't want her to
look at that chopper but again another
possible double meaning here perhaps a
nod to one to being the star
of this fake town and then notice agnes
is wearing that same pendant
we saw that before last episode this
could be a sign of her constancy
throughout this variable reality
she doesn't really change when it warps
she's just pretending that she's part of
it and then agnes talks about sending
scratchy's stage work he played baby
jesus in last year's christmas pageant
the son of god played by an animal it's
a little odd
dare i say sacrilegious because that
name senior scratchy
sounds like an odd to mr scratch or old
scratch which are nicknames for the
devil
agnes did say last episode her and
ralph's anniversary was
june 2nd the date the salem witch trials
began in 1692.
is that the date she married this
demonic figure
i'm just saying it sounds like we're
getting more clues that her husband
ralph that she can't shut up about and
this rabbit could just be the same devil
by different names
and then there's this bizarre moment
with a mailman oh morning dennis
stick him up don't shoot i'm just a
messenger
what was that maybe agnes is keeping a
close eye on what messages and
correspondents get in and out to this
town and right after this she focuses
wanda's anxiety on
a different evil queen bee dottie to
deflect from herself
and then there's that abject fear in
agnes face when wanda suggested just
being herself or maybe i could just be
myself
more or less
that is the last thing agnes wants she
wants wanda to play along with this
whole charade and never access her true
awareness now at the planning meeting uh
you might have caught this little gym
the devil's in the details bev that's
not the only place he is
ha i have been betting for months now
that this series will introduce marvel's
devil mephisto
whom agatha serves in the comics that's
who we think agnes is based
on so really any mentions of devils or
satanic elements we are going to need to
highlight
now sure you could read this as just
agnes throwing shade at dottie or
even hinting about the booze she was
about to whip out but then why would
wanda wave her away as if she already
knew what agnes was referring to before
seeing the flask
yeah agnes is hiding a lot and she's
thirsty in all kinds of ways she shows
up at suspicious times and she is now
talking about the devil hiding in places
it's coming together folks and again
thanks to privacy for sponsoring this
episode
start off the new year by cleaning up
your digital hygiene delete those old
unused apps and get a new one that will
make your digital life more secure and
organized like
privacy use privacy to protect your
personal information online and help
with budgeting and tracking your
spending privacy comes in handy with
recurring payments
like for streaming services and other
subscription services
i have set up an account with privacy
and i've linked my bank account and
created a card specifically for my
monthly
netflix subscription payment privacy
will ding you if someone tries to charge
the card twice or if the charge exceeds
the amount you set for it in this way in
case i need to suddenly cancel my
netflix subscription but i like
forget to do it netflix can't be like ah
we're gonna ding you for another month
privacy's got my back they're like ah
ah this card has some rules my friend so
just fill out your credit card info in
the privacy.com chrome in firefox
extension and you're only ever one click
away from spending smartly and safely
privacy protects your identity and bank
information on the internet and lets you
control the limits on each virtual card
privacy's added a
summary page to make it easy to track
your spending which is great for
budgeting purposes
and making sure those financial new
year's resolutions are not flushed by
february first head to privacy.com
new rockstars and sign up for an account
new customers will automatically get
five dollars to spend
on your first purchase go to privacy.com
new rockstars and sign up now and then
dottie says
all of this is for the children for the
children
for the children yeah it is pretty
creepy how much for the children gets
mindlessly parroted this episode
especially when you consider nowhere in
west view not even in the background
are any children visible where are the
[ __ ] kids this is a family town right
they talk about their kids but we do not
see them
clearly this isn't about the other
children of west view but
the children the whole town is designed
to trick wanda into bringing to life
that is what mephisto and agatha do to
wanda in the comics to drain wanda of
her chaos magic as wanda meets monica
who bullshits the name geraldine look
behind her i love how catherine hans
sips her boobs and just like really gets
into it
now meanwhile the men's neighborhood
watch are just a bunch of gossips
you know those bowling trophies arthur
is always polishing
we bought them all at a yard sale in
hackensack i knew it a
hackensack new jersey along with that
jersey area code another clue west view
and sword could be set up near camp
lehigh in new jersey
and also we did see arthur's fake
bowling trophies in the office last
episode
and i love how vision tries to play
along here
norm he's a communist the second time
cold war-era anti-communist sentiment
has come
up this season we don't break bread with
[ __ ] this whole red
scare motif parallels the fear of the
literal color red on this show
the helicopter dotty's blood the creepy
light on that toaster and the missing
big red gum that clogs vision's gears
didn't know that's how his body worked i
thought he could just like phase shift
food through him
but clearly he wanted to ingest this
it's interesting if you think about it
vision has kind of become the mr heart
of this episode he accuses others of
being communists and he
chokes dottie holds nothing back calling
out wanda but those accusations are
interrupted by the radio
this voice sounds a lot like jimmy wu
who does work for sword but more
importantly it tells us that wanda is
not
totally in control of westview she's at
least partially a victim
probably to some other third party who
is tricking her into wanting to stay in
this bubble but as wanda listens the
radio explodes
right as dotty shatters the glass
cutting her hand but then the help
miranda music resumes and the radio
is not broken anymore so yeah this
illusion just kind of patched its leak
and it used dottie's accident as a
misdirect then we get a commercial for
strucker swiss made watches
struck her he'll make time for you he'll
make time
for you
[Music]
there's even a hydro logo in the word
hydra on it striker is of course that
hydra leader who experimented on wanda
and pietro
using the mind stone to activate their
powers you remember him from the captain
winter soldier post credit scene in the
beginning of age of ultron it's not the
world of spies anymore
not even a world of heroes this is the
age
of miracles doctor there's nothing more
horrifying than a miracle
now if you think about the last
commercial was for a stark-made device
that beeped
kind of like a bomb about to go off much
like that stark projectile that did not
explode next to young pietro in wanda
but
made them always hate mr stark so now
this commercial is
also an expression of wanda's sokovian
past then at the talent show the gum
clogging visions gears make him seem
drunk
we will lie to you and yet you will
believe our little deception
because human beings are easily fooled i
feel like vision just drunkenly revealed
a big part of the show's deeper mystery
we are being deceived because we do not
fully understand the nature of
reality and how wanda can control it
vision keeps using
actual magic but wanda has to cover for
him by making them look like handmade
tricks
i like how very briefly agnes puts her
purse back down in relief making me
think
what was in that purse what was she
about to pull on them
also note that agnes is sitting with mrs
hart mr heart
ain't sitting there he is nowhere in
sight again talked about
but not there their neighbor's name is
revealed as herbs
it's herbert now i will say we are kind
of on a lookout for
a herbert in the mcu since we've been
theorizing that the high evolutionary
herbert windham might be introducing
guardians vol 3 maybe the geneticist who
made rocket the way he was
i'm not sure if this guy is gonna be the
same herbert though their magic act kind
of falls apart and wanda needs someone
to be in the cabinet as the crowd starts
referencing seven
what's
so they teleport monica in there and
agnes as if knowing this was impossible
actual magic
looks concerned to say the least so back
at home
with their victory trophy they connect
the dots on what for the children was
really all about
the children well i think the children
might need some popcorn
and boom out of nowhere big old baby
bump but then they hear another bump and
outside they see this
no ah so the beekeeper suit has a sword
logo suggesting this guy
is the same kind of intruder that monica
was that the helicopter was
but then warped into a new bizarre form
on the inside of the bubble and maybe
wanda's rejecting this outsider as we
know from the trailer footage that she
will do to monica at some point now if
you were to brighten up this guy
this is the face of actor zach henry the
stunt performer for the show and a
number of marvel productions
so really it's less about what mystery
actor this is and more about what this
character represents to wanda maybe we
can look at this pocket reality as a
kind of hive
wanda as the queen bee commanding the
drones rejecting the bee
keeper when it comes to reap the honey
also notice how both episodes one and
two
end with a hexagonal honeycomb wipe and
this episode opens with
six stars around the moon forming the
points of a hexagon
however you look at this i think this is
clearly a failed rescue attempt of wanda
she is so delusional that she wants to
stay trapped in this illusion
to move on to the next chapter rather
than close the book and wake up from the
dream
i'm not sure we can blame wanda for that
because as the voice repeats in the
final line
it is not her who's doing this who's
doing this to you wanda
follow me and darla on instagram at
eavos follow me rockstar subscribe to
the rockstars hit that notification bell
we're going to be talking a lot more
about one division in the weeks ahead so
until next week
want division one one division help
miranda oh gotta get demonetized
[Music]
you